In 2003, a ground breaking genetics report that
performed the y chromosome analysis, revealed that a significant
proportion of men alive today, are actually direct line
decendants from one man who lived about 1000 years
ago. A whopping 16 million of men alive today
actually share the same y chromosome. That's like 0.5%
of the world population of men, or about one
in 200 men. So how did a y chromosome
spread so fast in only about 30 generations?
Almost all the evidence points to a single man,
Genghis Khan. About 10% of all men living
within the borders of what was once the Mongul
Empire, share the same y chromosome. And Genghis
Khan was a warlord. An emperor of the Mongol
Empire who gained land mainly thru battle and trade.
Now the key to understanding how his y chromosome
might have spread so fast is not so hidden in a
quote that's attributed to him and the methods of his empire
expansion. The greatest joy of a man is to defeat his
enemies. To drive them before him and to take from them
all they possess. To see they love in tears, to ride
their horses and to hold their wives and daughters in his
arms. And Genghis Khan was one of the most ruthless warriors
who ever lived. And his y chromosome has been so successful
in part, because of forcible rape and
reproduction of the many women that he came
in contact with. And now 0.5% of the world is the genetic evidence to prove it.